tonight marks the first return to
staples center for 2020 nba world
champion alex caruso
turn your attention now to the video
board for our special tribute
in your mind right
finally does the person who competes
with their head as well as their body
come in second
[Applause]
[Music]
kick out caruso for the lead got it to
go
alex caruso puts south bay up by one
goes up slam it down
alex caruso with the flush
caruso
a thrilling ride for the los angeles
lakers
it's nba it's the next next man up so
i'm just taking advantage of my
opportunity
[Music]
[Applause]
the guy that we know that we can count
on
doesn't make many mistakes on the floor
and just plays winning basketball that's
just who he is
[Applause]
he's doing what he's supposed to do he
comes in in limited minutes he wrecks
havoc fans love him
10 out of 10 10 out of 10.
we'll kick it out for alex on its way
for three
[Applause]
peanut butter
on a hot
dog
[Music]
[Music]
with a big hit blocked
[Music]
in orlando the lakers are the world
champions
and to be here now three four years
later however the years have been really
fulfilling man
this makes it worth it it makes it so
worth it
that's all welcome
back world champion alex caruso
what a tribute